the following is a conversation with
stephen codkin his second time on the
podcast
stephen is one of the greatest
historians of all time specializing in
20th and 21st century history of russia
and eastern europe
and he has written what is widely
considered to be the definitive
biography of stalin in three volumes two
of which have been published and the
third
focused on world war ii and the years
after he is in the midst of writing now
this conversation includes a response to
my previous podcast episode with oliver
stone that was focused on vladimir putin
and the war in ukraine
stephen provides a hard-hitting
criticism of putin and the russian
invasion of ukraine
weighed and contextualized deeply in the
complex geopolitics and history of our
world
all with an intensity and rigor but also
wit and humor that makes steven one of
my favorite human beings
please also allow me to mention
something that has been apparent and has
weighed heavy on my heart and mind
this conversation with stephen codkin
makes it more dangerous for me to travel
in russia
the previous conversation with oliver
stone
makes it more dangerous for me to travel
in ukraine
this makes me sad
but it is the way of the world
i will nevertheless travel to both
ukraine and russia
i need to once again see with my own
eyes
the land of my ancestors
where they suffered but flourished
and eventually gave birth
to silly old me
i need to hear directly the pain anger
and hope from both ukrainians and
russians
i won't give details to my travel plans
in terms of location and timing but the
trip is very soon
whatever happens
i'm truly grateful for every day i'm
alive
and i hope to spend each such day adding
a bit of love to the world
i love you all
you